*Footsteps*
(hurgh)
*claps*
It's time for another episode of drinking whiskey.
Welcome this fine evening
We are doing, ha! you guessed it the last thing on the list: a bourbon
Marzia: What is Bourbon whiskey?
Oh
Bourbon that is well, it's defined by many different things
I'm glad you asked
Generally the easiest way to tell them apart is by region bourbon is America it has to be just like Scotch
Has certain rules bourbon has rules as well defined by law so it has to be at least,
Oh no
I think it has to be more than 51% by eh, corn distilled by corn so Scotch is more like
malted barley and
But you get bourbon which is distilled  with corn yeah aged in new charred, charred oak containers
Which is what gives it, bourbon, it's very distinct more
Goldish tone
Gold is not the right word brownish.
Yeah, red. Bourbon...
Is very nice
Very nice, I've tried all of these and they are all
Very nice. This is the first time I actually cheated
I was supposed to record this video long ago
But there was just such immense pressure from you guys to make another one of these episodes
When is the next episode Felix?
I'm dying here. Here we are
Finally with the Bourbon the last of the series this will be my last
We're gonna start with a Cyrus Noble, which is the most expensive one, guess how much this one cost?
Two hundred and seventy two I think but it's a lot of whiskey you got a lot of whiskey for that price
compared to the other ones
I'm glad you're asked because that's a mistake me and Jack made in the last video
So this is 80 proof which means it's 45% alcohol, there you go
Let's try that Cyprus Noble straight bourbon whiskey this is from, Kentucky
Fun fact about Kentucky whiskey there are more barrels of whiskey than are people living there
Don't know if that's actually true. I need to start fact-checking better accepting things rough
Yeah
So 95% of all bourbon is pro- produced, Kentucky
Kentucky bird - Kentucky whiskey Burnham's the state has more than
5.3 million barrels of bourbon that are aging, a number that exceeds the state population, I was right. Cheers!
That sounds like a good we need a move into Kentucky. Can you imagine?
That's incredible now. I did realize it for myself one hell of a glass, but let's give it a let's give it a try
It's got that very distinct bourbon-y spicy flavor
Sniff on it. It smells beautiful. I could smell this no you don't know
Now, this is exactly how you want bourbon to taste like. I really enjoyed this bourbon. It's
Very nice
The meme is so dead. It's a strong flavor
It's not unlike
Scotch which has a strong, a lot of Scotch has a strong flavor, but they don't but they're very usually a very smoky
This is that same strong flavor, but without the smoke smokiness, it's more spicy
Yeah, Jefferson's reserved it says very old on the bottle very old, Kentucky straight bourbon
But that's the thing with bourbon, nothing is very old, America is not very old. There's a lot of stories about the origin of
Bourbon
Generally people just agree on that the scotch King, the Scottish people came and they're like "hey we want to drink something
What do you got here to make some some fine whiskey" and they're like "hey, we got corn!"
I mean, I'm just making this up by the way. This is another
Kentucky based
Kentucky god bless you, we should go to Kentucky
It's a very small batch bourbon aged longer than its deployments for an extra slab of spicy
Complexity, very nice. I guess the thing with with drinks is that, maybe I should just drink it
I actually think I like that one more than hmm. Do you want to smell it okay?
I think the Cypress isn't better overall
The flavor in your mouth when you have their reserve. It's beautiful
But I'm not sure if I like the kick the spicy kick that it describes. It is significantly cheaper
But it's also
Very nice
Yeah, I
Think that's it. Yeah something 76 maybe. None of the Bourbons are very expensive
I would say compared to the Scotch the personal prices of the Scotch is pretty outrageous
1964 that's when they declared that bourbon was bourbon by my state of law so
Bourbon is pretty young they've been making it for a longer time obviously
But has bourbon hasn't been bourbon for more than a hundred years at least even though they've been making bourbon for more than 100 years
Garrison brothers everybody, this is a Texas straight bourbon whiskey
So it's not from, Kentucky. Hi
This is the most cowboy whiskey I've seen and they really try and promote it that way I think they have a bourbon cold Cowboys
that's the thing with the
That I think I really
Enjoy about whisky it sounds a bit pretentious, but it's more than just a drink. It's it's immersing yourself in
An experience you drink the Laphroaig and you imagine yourself in Scotland you drink some bourbon
From, Texas, and you feel like a cowboy you know what I mean
Yeah
The flavors are all so different. I don't know how to describe it the spicy flavors man the spicy
I keep going and spicy but none of them really feels fantastic to me. They're all very nice, but so far
It's not it's not like some of the Irish whiskey that I tried that are just like them. Oh my god
This is all I want to drink except. They have the COBOL
Single berry whiskey rye distilled in Chicago this one tastes crazy. That's all I remember
Yeah, it's very different
Very very different they all taste so different from each other, but this one tastes
Particularly different, it's so strange
Some bourbon is so strange. I don't even know if this is bourbon this tastes less
I was just gonna say this one tastes. Not as strong as the other ones, but I guess you would disagree
But I do like it obviously I drank quite a lot from it, but I don't I don't know
Next one I am
Very excited about this is 100% straight corn whiskey so it's not bourbon. Oh, that's the thing I forgot to tell about this one cuz
this is
Hey, I just noticed that there's a difference between
Kentucky Bourbon and Tennessee bourbon, I think the bottle that it couldn't find was the Tennessee bourbon
And they really try to make themself their own thing in Tennessee it seems like they're like
Oh, we're not bourbon. We're we're Tennessee whiskey alright calm down
This one clearly feels like they took moonshine and marketed it kind of they got a freaking wizard
I try this one it's one of the cheaper ones. It's actually very nice. It's actually really good
I can see since 100% corn. It's a lot
Brighter than the other ones it looks so much like Irish whiskey this feels like that kind of stuff you today
You drink with some ice maybe you don't have to be like oh
Oh, yeah
Way less flavors than all of the others, but it still tastes
real smooth I
Really like it. I don't know. I just bought it because I was like holy crap that bottle looks insane
Maker's mark has been put on the map recently becoming very popular in the UK. It's a Kentucky straight bourbon whiskey
Handmade they put I don't know what that in place. I think when you get to the really cheaper whiskeys
Typically you wouldn't really enjoy it like the rest
But this is one of the cheaper ones that I actually would really enjoyed this did get a lot better
So much flavor so much spice you feel like cowboy last
But not least the Jack Daniels Jack Daniels has set specific flavor
And it goes really well with mixing if you want to make yourself a highball
It's very nice to do that learning sparkling powder and some Jack Daniels
And you got yourself a highball and it's it's a very nice drink
I mean doesn't dehydrate you like a lot of other drinks
Do like we keep drinking gin and tonics or keep drinking all these fancy drinks?
You're not gonna feel good the day after but you drink just whiskey water
You know you can't go better the night Jack Daniels everybody that whiskey that
probably most of you that are watching have tried its a
Tennessee whiskey and they make they go out of their way to say oh, no, we're not a bourbon we're a Tennessee whiskey see
That's what I was getting at before apparently what they do is they drink the whiskey through charcoal
Charcoal is that possible that's what gives it its really distinct flavor, and it is so it is a nice flavor
I understand why it's so popular. I think because it has a brief black label. They did a really good job market again
We study actually this
Economy how they market it and black really put them on the market. That's a manly you know product
You see people all the time like yeah, we could Jack that man right. It's my last
It's been fun guys. It's been fun all the memories
It's been so many memories so many wonderful times, I want to thank you guys for this opportunity
I want to thank the all the community of whiskey drinkers and most of all I want to thank myself
Here's to me
That was it that was all the whiskey
Might do another video if I got enough thumbs up, can we get this to trending a final wish?
Are you live for me? You don't think I can get trending challenge accepted everybody
um
That was that good
Goodbye, everybody and remember keep drinking
safely
Water drink water